well with that introduction we're all
right yeah so you know on the note I
just what I think it's worthwhile to
take a second to say obviously thank you
for inviting me but it's really hard for
those of us who organize conferences to
do something that both has like depth in
an area and captures people from our
broad audience usually get to kind of
either do a large conference or you know
have kind of a small focus group so it's
a kind of a remarkable thing so the
organizers particularly Michael and
Jennifer done an amazing job I think and
i actually along those lines have done
something asked us to which i revised my
talk heavily last night based on the
previous talks because there are so many
relevant points of contact and so what
i'm going to do is talk sort of about
some of the work I've been doing that
slow to led me up to the current project
and the second half of the talk is going
to talk all about through the new stuff
I'm doing and in many ways the open
question that we kind of led me into
this area of research was you know how
to contagion spread and this is a figure
that should be kind of familiar to
everyone in the network and in the room
right and you know we say look these are
highly stylized graphs we kind of a you
know a locally clustered lattice
networks and rewiring and massive
rewiring and this affects that obviously
propers the topology clustering path
length also properties the dynamics one
thing to emphasize is that when we talk
about why select certain graphs or white
look at certain graphs especially
leading from models into data sort of
the converse of what Jennifer is talking
about there are reasons theoretically
why we think these are relevant right
these aren't just sort of arbitrary
things that we're studying because
they're available I mean this is a cute
model to toy model in physics right but
substantively we think spatial models
are important a lot of phenomena that we
study in terms of social spreading
happen in spatial networks and we also
think that these sort of casual context
which you know random ties weak ties
long ties right as a category of social
structure also affects spreading
dynamics that's a meaningful way of
interpreting the sort of the the
relevant social space and so just to
make the intuition clear we've all seen
this a lot but you know we have to
innovators showing its blue notes me
look at like kind of a social contact
rule and spreading should have
propagates around a lot of structure
alright this is kind of the familiar
thing neighbor to neighbor around the
network and then we introduce some sort
of rewire ties spreading is faster and
when we require ton of ties and
spreading is a ton faster right this
gives us some very clear intuitions and
we think we're interested in the spread
of diseases where it shouldn't spread of
you know information word-of-mouth
dynamics Richard and square the
behaviors everything ranging from new
technologies to social movements to you
know health innovations and this is
where I want to push back a little bit
from the point of view of theory and
when I say theory here what I mean is a
substantive interpretation of what's
going on in the individuals head right
not from an fMRI scan point of view but
there's no point of view of reasons
right why do people make decisions why
do people adopt or not adopt so the
point of view of a simple contagion like
a disease right often just a contact of
sufficient so there's actually not a lot
of interpretation from an epidemiology
perspective but what's going on in the
head it doesn't matter right contact is
sufficient for transmission and so all
you know is there's a link and it
propagates from person to person an
information propagation is sort of
similar to write you learn the score of
the game there's not a lot of sort of
thinking going on you just learn this
school and you can repeat it to someone
else and so on and so forth and that
map's pretty well into those dynamics we
were just looking at right but then the
point I want to push on is when we think
about substantive behavior change right
for any number of behaviors that we made
care about in different domains either
you know adopting a new technology or
making a health decision like getting a
screening or trying a new medication or
joining a social movement where there
may be real consequences sometimes we
need to be convinced to do it right we
think the more costly the difficult
unfamiliar and potentially painful or
dangerous the behavior is the more that
social reinforcement is but a necessary
factor for the decision-making process
and this is where when you know we talk
about theory we think well there are
different reasons why this would be the
case right now we're really thinking
this is doing sociology and social
psychology like really thinking about
why it is that a given node in the
network would change right and so when
you
we're thinking about really what the
behavior is what the contagion is that
spreading right in some cases uncertain
to your risk plays a role right as more
people do a behavior the behavior itself
is more credible we believe that this is
something that's a good idea your
technology comes along it's extremely
costly should we invest in it so we
invest in a new market right well as we
see more people do we believe that the
market investment is it is a good one
normative validation this is a has the
same dynamics as more people adopt we
believe that we should do the behavior
but the underlying social mechanism is
different social mechanisms like a
technical term in sociology there aren't
that many technical terms in sociology
right but this is one of them and like
all technical terms of sociology is
incredibly big right so this is this is
an attempt to fertilize it a little bit
right this is what that mature may
actually mean and so we can say well
normative validation is the kind of
thing where you put people into a
situation and just by virtue of the fact
that more people are doing it I feel
pressure I feel sort of a sense of a
desire to conform right this has been
studied a ton in the lab all right you
know going back to the 50s thinking
about this kind of this kind of social
dynamic is different from a risk one
certainty dynamic it's not that we're
one certainly feel actual pressure a
different kind of incentive is a
straight economic one this is not social
is not peer pressure it's just that the
inherent value of the behavior can
change but I think of this with all
kinds of complementary technologies
right with phones right with fax
machines with anything where the more
people who have the technology the more
valuable the technology is right so just
the fact of knowing where people with it
Facebook is a great example of it too or
the fact that people being in that space
makes us want to be in that space right
and so I you know over the course of two
thousand seven thousand eight those nine
there's a series of formal models
mathematical models that you know expand
on the the simple small world model and
take the intuition you know all the way
back to sort of classical sociology and
so you know if we really think about
diffusion processes in this way and
assume that it's a simple contagion itís
not versus a complex contagion we get
really different intuitions about the
fusion in fact for complex contagions
where social reinforcement is needed
spatial networks actually can do a
better job
using things faster and diffusing things
farther the networks with these weak
ties but it's a sort of a striking
intuition goes back about 40 years in
sociology exactly four years in
sociology that we've been saying for a
long time at these sort of random ties
facilitate diffusion right so starting
from the intuition that it leads us into
like a natural big question which is yep
yeah that's right well it's nothing
there's nothing interesting it's it's
but what are the characteristics of
interests right instead what is no I
understand very well somewhat with local
structure this well they're small world
network and smaller topology right and
so Newman makes this clear in the 2000
review but essentially the point is that
if we think of our sort of main relevant
characteristics as local cluster right
and and we say well there's some value
to that local clustering or basically as
we approach a random graph do we just
approach our pretty fast as possible and
so this is something I'm going to point
out next couple slides but what a useful
so in physics with this idea of
idealization right point masses and
stuff like this well in sociology
there's a kind of a corollary term and
of course it's much more big but it's
called ideal types and so we say well
real networks are super messy but we
isolate some characteristics that we
think are relevant so one characteristic
isolate is that you know the level of
clustering which innocence in essence is
the level of redundancy so if we take it
from like the simplest point of view we
say what information diffusion is
fastest when there's the lowest possible
bring other than C and there's a lowest
possible four dozen see a network that's
completely random so an expectation no
neighbors our neighbor no neighbors are
neighbors of each other and that means
that every single contact leads to a new
personally seen personally seen a person
you get your shirt maximum exposure at
each step right and so we say okay let's
take that which is our ideal case and
contrast it with the other case which is
where everyone is locally embedded in
basically a uniform lattice which is
your other ideal case and so that's
going to be the kind of the way that we
frame the next piece of this just to
kind of a securities
that's right that's right or right no
i'm not i'm not talking about right he
he identified in the original papers
identify that kind of special space
where there's both that's right and
there's a really nice intuition for that
which is i mean there's a lot of deep
there's a lot of deep stuff going on in
that paper that isn't that's actually
interestingly connected to social theory
which is that you know they this idea if
you take a first-person perspective your
world kind of looks clustered still by
the diameter of the network changes and
it's it's a very interesting intuition
the weirdest thing should hear the macro
level dynamics and we're saying if we
were to just eliminate redundancy
entirely right and get our kind of ideal
case for rapid information spreading
what would that mean then for a behavior
spreading her for complex contagion so
that's the way the question is raised
our assumption that there's a cost to
contact
too much cost or
oh no it's just it's a simple it's
basically the simple sort of percolation
dynamic so this is a straight sword
macro-level cisco mechanics description
of diffusion right it's basically saying
well if we had our fastest case scenario
assuming simple contagion does that also
mean that things are equally good to me
a complex contagion right that's the
next thing and so if we have a
prediction the prediction is as we
assume that behavior is a more complex
and has these dependencies about social
reinforcement that in fact a network
structure should affect spreading in a
way that's really different from the way
that simple contagious diffuse and this
raises the question that you know kind
of leads us all on this whole this whole
range of research which is how would we
ever evaluate that empirically so this
is a big claim I mean theoretically
we've got lots and lots of theory again
not just the small world model but
previously 40 years in sociology arguing
this sort of point generally constructed
and then we've also got of course
massive implications right if you design
a health intervention how should you see
to what should you expect but the
network diffusion if you think the
disease spreads one way do you think a
preventative behavior would spread the
same way or what it spread differently
as I mean you should look at different
kinds of networks than the ones the
disease is growing alone right so we
think about this really substantively
and then this really leads us into the
problem of how how would we ever do this
how would we ever study this kind of
thing and you know one of the points is
that we really haven't been able to
write one issue is scale this is really
important to scale is something that
matters theoretically that we have in
physical mechanics you describe what are
called finite size effects which are
exactly what they sound like so if you
run a model with 10 people you get one
result you run the same exact model same
exact dynamics with a hundred people or
a thousand people you get the exact
opposite result right so if you're
interested in the dynamics at a thousand
or more at scale then you just can't
study with 10 people because you'll
you'll get the wrong intuition so it
matters then of course if you really
want to study have something spreading
you to know the real time dynamics of
influence and change then you have all
these problems that we typically do some
hand waving on in not just in social
science besides generally right we say
controlling unobserved head
is really really hard so we kind of make
some assumptions but these things matter
really right if we want to tease apart
these different calls and mechanisms
like we have a structural theory about
health apology as as an independent
variable affects some kind of collective
outcome and then reproducibility becomes
very very important now because we've
said we've got that kind of claim we'd
like to say is it doesn't just happen
once right a kind of thing they kind of
thought experiment to imagine is imagine
if we could identify a contagion process
right imagine if that wasn't a problem
empirically if we knew for sure it was
contagion process would that tell us
everything we need to know right answer
is no if we watched a real canadian
process in one network once there's all
kinds of other stuff that could be
happening because of the massive
interdependence of variables and the
correlation of variables like homophily
network effects leadership roles and so
forth right so if we want to really
control that we need to reproduce it
across different conditions and so
that's where internet experiments come
in and one of the things I want to
suggest is that this isn't just one
method among others right this is
compass is a conjecture but you know
with the advent of big data we're
thinking about new powerful ways of
doing lab research the intuition here is
that web based social dynamics or
internet experiments specifically give
us a way of studying the causal effects
of the structural variables of networks
on collective behaviors in a way that we
just couldn't have done before right and
so the intuition here this is kind of a
cute rope as the social petri dish right
so we build a little world you put
people in it and we study how they
behave right that's kind of cool because
we can see them sort of grow and change
and maybe we get some kind of fungus out
of it or even if we get penicillin out
of it who knows right but then we can do
it again and again and again we can
replicate these little petri dishes next
to each other and that gives us like an
incredible analytical power and the
point I want to make and they sort of
i'm going to hasten to contradict myself
right now right i want to say yeah we
can do that but we could have done that
in the lab too right so what's different
right I want to say what's different is
that unlike in the lab we're not
bringing people into a setting that's an
artificial setting when I give
behavior to do that they don't quite
understand or that has really narrow
constraints what we do here as we go to
the natural environment right these are
sort of experiments not wild we're
basically going to a space that people
participate in any way right perfect and
you think about all the kinds of things
that people do online right and they you
know they buy stuff they sell stuff they
date download music they interact they
sign up for health programs they do all
these real things so if we can just go
to those spaces where people are doing
real things we can study their real
behavior right and we can study in this
way just like a petri dish so this is
something I built a few years ago so
science in 2010 and basically the idea
here is that you know I built an online
health network and just recruited people
from me from the world from the universe
right who are these people right there
not being paid why are they coming this
is the this is the question genetic
yourselves like why do they care right
you basically just built something and
said hey come join the health lifestyle
Network these are people who are like
intrinsically interested in health and
health behavior and then I you know
built apologies ahead of time and then
see put them in the typologies again if
you look at a lab experiment and said I
built a topology and put people in it
you say oh yeah that makes sense but as
soon as you do it online in like a real
world setting like everyone has this
reaction of like we'll wait you both
it's a pouch but how why how could that
possibly work that means you put people
into a network and said these are your
neighbors interact right want to lab it
makes sense because you're basically
being told to do it because you're being
paid for some outcome but in the real
world why do they care right well they
care of the same reason that we got a
tripadvisor and you sign up for you know
you want to get a hotel you see a bunch
of random people that you've never met
make ratings about hotels and two three
four of them say this is a bad hotel I'm
not going to go you'll change your
decision about what hotel you're going
to stay at even these are completely
random people to you they're anonymous
right and so in this space people care
about this sort of health information or
in the in the particular study I'm
actually doing i actually defuse a
behavior and when they're embedded in
these networks what they see is this
right there's no sense of the network
there's no sense of Thai they don't have
they have no network theoretic
realization in this
it's just kind of a first-person
perspective on the world right I'm a guy
I signed up I have my username and
avatar with some characteristics other
peoples have had have user name user
names and avatars with their
characteristics right and so when I look
at me I'm like I know the process they
went through to make this you know
profile and I attribute that same this
is a really interesting point I
attribute that same behavior to these
people right I give them full
backstories right I kind of manufacture
for them meaning in the social space
because I went through this process and
presumably they went through it as well
and it's amazing to me like I actually
controlled all the messages so they all
came from the health lifestyle network
and said you're you know your body
signed up for this you know this is
health program that we've initiated do
you want to sign up to and so that was
the problem was a real propagation
dynamic but people couldn't email each
other because you know anonymity right
protects for IRB reasons but people
would respond to the server and say
things like have you tried this diet or
have you you know have you you know I'm
interested in doing this program have
you try mean they actually like engage
with these other health buddy says as
people with you know actions and reasons
and backstories ya know this is the
point is that this topology here the one
on the left hand side I'll show you even
more clearly these typologies the one on
the left hand side that's clustered on
the right hand side that's random these
are these are constructed ahead of time
so as people come in they're basically
put into a node and the people they're
connected to are the buddies who show up
when i seed it with a behavior then it
was showing son Ian for this health
program and we can just watch it spread
again the beauty of these data are
they're just you know the science paper
just reported count data right there's
no fancy statistics here it's just let's
watch the spreading which is our
fundamental in our intuition and we can
see that what happens here is even
though these signals are locally
constrained that generates redundancy
right in redundancy create social
reinforcement which generates sort of a
spreading process and hear the signal is
going out throughout the network right
the simple contagion people are finding
out about it but the adoption is far
less right the sort of pulls of the
movie like actually illustrates
something that it's harder to get just
from looking at the data which is that
this the diffusion
process has kind of a characteristic of
kind of neighborhood spillover in large
worlds is a simulation these are the
actual data unmodified what's being at
all I had people sign up for a health
program where they could you know share
health resources so is basically signing
up to be a member of this health program
this is among network is this
pre-specified topology in which you are
dropping down people who register for
your site basically right yeah so
there's two steps people have to come
join the study and you put them
somewhere missed apology and then you're
somewhere in the topology you're
randomly assigned to conditions
obviously in the randomly side note
isn't a condition adoption is not the
registration itself that's some
additional action some additional action
so I did build you have to build a
series of products basically right so
this thing is a product and then within
that you have to build a second product
which is the thing you're going to
diffuse right and that that eliminates
entirely unobserved heterogeneity
because no one can find out about this
except for this diffusion process yeah
yeah so that's good too so this is where
the mate that's a great question this is
where the mechanisms come in we design a
study like this you've got theory which
says we think this should work and why
and the reason we think is well in this
case as people more people adopted this
program there were other people to
interact with in short share health
recommendations with and so the idea
kind of intuition I had is well the
fundamental mechanism here is one of
strategic interdependence of
complementarity right and then that's
what's increasing because you can you
can see that more and more health
buddies are adopting it presents the
signal that oh this is an increasingly
valuable thing for me to do all right
but that was I mean that's why the
theory is helpful because you're doing
the experimental design the whole time
it's like art which mechanism do i think
is at work here and then how to identify
that mechanism with the actual
construction of the study and then the
one of the big punch lines here is our
eyes 128 people in this network 128
people on that network and then I did I
replicated right these trials six times
that's what like 15 36 people right any
question is what is N and my clean here
is a causal effect of the network on
behavior which means my claim is that
there are six observations you
condition right so my total n is 12 all
right and now I can make a causal claim
I can say well these are independent
these are iid by construction and now we
can say if there's a difference across
every single condition every single
trial then we've got a causal effect of
network structure and behavior change
it's a new way of thinking I I think
about these kinds of diffusion dynamics
where we can think really about
populations as individual samples and
then we can compare them collectively
and then the nice thing is that we can
also dig down to the individual level
and remind ourselves we have a theory
here about why these collective dynamics
should be this way which is that
behaviors complex that require social
reinforcement we have such good data
that we can actually find that so got a
micro level description of what the
behavior isn't a macro level dynamic and
they match up very nicely so and I see a
series of papers then I kind of explored
you know if we I did a second paper the
follow-up year that looked at home
awfully again as a manipulable variable
not as something we discovered Pyrrhic
Lee but changing you say the
characteristics and the vector of traits
people have putting people in one
network where the vector traits were
more overlapping and similar which is a
vector of traits was like kind of
randomly distributed and saying well how
did that really affect diffusion and we
have theories met and I some of that you
people actually have like models of this
predicting it but those models I mean
they're interesting but give it's very
very hard empiric way to really think
about what homophily means is a causal
effect on diffusion so as I said a
series of papers looking at these kinds
of things but this has led me to what
I'm working on now which is you know
real behavior typically from like a
normative perspective the things we care
about aren't just things that are seated
in the network externally right there
endogenous there like a lot of us have
strategies and ideas and we kind of
learn from each other and the more that
I do something maybe you react and your
reactions actually affect my
interpretation of my own behaving and
political opinions this way right we
make coalesce around something but
that's really a process of coalescence
it's not just that something was seated
in there spread and so the contagion
story is I think a kind of a narrow
subset of the kind of dynamic that we're
interested in when we think about social
processes especially when it comes to
norms I think of like linguistic
conventions how we all agree on you know
certain ways of talking of course the
terms like spam become classic examples
of this like why do we all talk call
junk email spam all right why do we well
because everyone else does all right it
becomes a convenient way of talking
about it economic inventions standards
of fare bargaining right I mean these
are things that are basically just
established through social interactions
and then once it's established then
everyone agrees on it social conventions
these things about like gender norms
which we've seen evolve in society and
we've seen sort of points of contact
right where that's actually caused
tension and then as they evolved and it
sort of a Greek coalescence around and
then industry conventions web two point
oh and other things like that and so the
game here I want to talk about very very
quickly at the end is is basically based
on the standard model of how linguistic
invention to merge there's an object
here and you look at the object and you
say a name bah i look at the object and
i look at the knee you know i say small
right and then we say okay you said blah
i said slaw and now we kind of update
our memories rice is a very simple kind
of toy physics ii model of a cow this
might work and there are more
sophisticated game theoretic models like
peyton young other people have developed
they're really going to flush out you
know in some circumstances how we think
this happens and so social norms here
are emerging for the endogenous
interaction right and so this is an
evolutionary story right we've
eliminated you know leadership from an
external source we've eliminated kind of
authority figures driving coordination
because like if we just have people
interacting trying to figure out these
you know these answers to like what's
the best way to coordinate on it they
don't really care what the world is
doing normally know it the world is
doing but they care very much with the
people that are interacting with are
doing right and this is dragging their
expectations and so this is the name
game right and along the lines of stuff
that was described earlier so give a
bunch of people who you're playing with
you've got an object that you're trying
to name in this case it's a pitcher a
woman's face and you got a series of
rounds then series of rounds is fixed
time limit obviously you get some
winnings for matching if you as Michael
pointed out it's hard to penalize people
for losing because that's called
gambling but you they're really strict
IRB
limitations on being able to do that but
you can penalize people down to zero
right and it turns out interesting
people are more responsive to the game
when you penalize them versus like just
give them no response for losing so so
here that you know they depend lies but
they have no information about what
their neighborhood looks like and in the
given interaction they don't even know
which of these people they're
interacting with so it could be 20
interactions with the same person or it
could be one interaction across everyone
there have no idea so it's like really
you have no information about the social
world you're in right in the question is
well if you're just engaged in this
process of like trying to repeatedly
name can we actually figure out that
problem and just to show you some this
is just live data and work the papers
under progress for submission so I was
going to show you some of the light
then I think that the exciting question
now in terms of open questions is this
approach of doing this kind of research
gives way to a just an incredibly large
set of questions we can ask right about
these dynamics about the
interdependencies about all kinds of
organizational structures and so you
know I think this is the open question
that I'm very interested in how people
think about is what it whatever women's
have this sort of approach yeah thank
you